[Musique]
bienvenue une opa sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire
mais chez moi confinement oblige on va
parler passé pardon tout cette émission
avec franck lepage qui est militant de
l'éducation populaire
une vedette de l'homme d'aran de la
contre-culture connu grâce à ses
fameuses conférences gesticulées dans a
donné plus de 500 beaucoup regardé pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles sur
internet bonjour franche lepage comment
vous portez-vous bonjour vers jean
minable c'est plus de 65 ans donc tout
va bien
vous pouvez donc vous restez chez vous
alors une de vos conférences les plus
célèbres c'est celle vous expliquer la
novlangue la langue de bois est ce que
vous avez de thé une langue de bois
particulière depuis le début du
confinement et de l'épidémie du choléra
virus
alors il ya la langue de bois évidemment
qui concerne toute la santé toutes les
politiques de santé et notamment de de
leur privatisation
on nous en a sorti une pas mal hier le
préfet par le préfet et le directeur de
la rs du grand est si vous avez vu ça
qui a qui a fait savoir qu'il y aurait
aucune raison d'arrêter le processus de
modernisation et de performance de
l'offre de soins hospitaliers après
cette crise sanitaire et que donc on
maintenait la suppression de 599 poste
au chu nancy est de 175 lits et donc
pour dire ça il justifie sa part la
modernisation et la performance de
l'offre de soins hospitaliers
ça c'est discours alors sur le corps
d'un virus lui-même enfant en pleurs
paix la langue de bois il
elle a deux tendances une tendance qui
consiste à effet misé qu'on veut pas de
ce dont on veut cacher la violence ou au
contraire à amplifier ce qu'on veut
enfin les ennemis pour prendre un
exemple très simple quand vous avez cinq
minutes de retard à la ratp vous avez
une prise d'otage d'accord donc là on
n'est pas dans l'euphémisme on est dans
l'hyperbole
ou quand quelqu'un jette j'ai pas quoi
un fer à béton sur un tgv c'est à du
vandalisme
ça devient du terrorisme donc là l'effet
de l'effet il est très très clair dans
le discours de macron notamment celles
appel à la guerre bien sûr répéter cette
fois nous sommes en guerre ça ne va pas
du tout nous ne sommes plus en guerre
pour le reste je dirais que essentielle
de la langue de bois son camp la fin sur
le sur le corner virus c'est de noyer le
poisson c'est de nous c'est de nous
priver de toute information on ne
comprend rien si on ne va pas chercher
soi-même sur internet de l'information
chez les chez les gens il ya ya ya rien
qui est dit sur les chaînes
c'est vrai que je devais avait publié un
texte coville 19 l'ami des dominants sûr
qu'on peut lire sur le site de l'arber
s'en prenait aux chiffres qui nous sont
données en permanence mais jamais en
regard de quoi que ce soit ce qui fait
que ces chiffres sont incompréhensibles
didou tout à fait une autre a eu nos
stratégies de la langue de bois c'est
les statistiques j'sais pas si vous
connaissez peut-être la blague 98 perse
98 % des gens croient une statine une
information si elles contiennent
statistiques en fait cette communication
sur les médias dominants sur france 2 ou
autre elle tourne en boucle sur trois
informations qui sont chaque jour de
nous annoncer un nombre de décès qui est
plus grand que la veille sans que ces
décès ne soit jamais rapporté à rien
c'est à dire que moi me dire il ya 400
morts ça peut être très effrayant que ça
peut l'être pas tellement si on met en
regard d'autres chiffres notamment les
chiffres des gens qui meurent
normalement c'est à dire chaque année de
causes naturelles comme on dit c'est
vrai que 400 morts à l'aune des 600 6000
décès chaque année
ça peut paraître peu plus grande 1 618
1000 décès cette année elle sur le voilà
cela s'appelle la démographie et puis
vous avez sept cent mille naissances
sur ces six cent mille on va simplifier
sur ses six cent mille décès vous en
avez par exemple ça ce sont les chiffres
du ministère de la santé s'est passé
c'est pas le groupuscule gauchiste du
coin donc l'adresse la direction des
études et de la statistique du ministère
de la santé nous informe qu'il ya cent
cinquante mille décès dans les ehpad
chaque année 150 milles alors quand on
vous annonce que c'est sûr c'est pas 85
à 84 me alors ça c'est un autre chiffre
que j'avais trouvé mais a depuis on a
revérifier sur les chiffres du ministère
86000 c'était parce qu'ils annoncent que
14 % de morts dans les ehpad mais il
faut rajouter ça veut devenir technique
un faut ajouter les 54 % de morts dans
des structures hospitalières et donc
vous avez une perméabilité parce que les
vieux ne meurt pas tous à l'ehpad c'est
à dire que quand c'est un ehpad qui
n'est pas équipé d'un système de soin on
va le faire mourir à l'hôpital d'accord
bon bref le ministre je comprends mais
auquel reconnaissez franck lepage que si
au moment où on apprend que plus de
mille personnes sont mortes dans les
ehpad depuis le début du confinement si
on disait brossé pas grand chose par
rapport aux 91
cent mille morts habituel chaque année
ça choquerait tout le monde vous compris
et moi compris non oui c'est juste que
ces chiffres ne sont pas éclairés et je
peux rien faire avec un chiffre pareil
quand on me dit j'ai regardé les
chiffres en bretagne j'habite en
bretagne on est à 88 morts
bon la dernière fois que j'avais regardé
c'est la semaine dernière on était à 32
morts ok 32 morts de 32 à 88 c'est moche
c'est vraiment pas terrible
80 humeur il ya trois eu trois millions
et demi de personnes en bretagne s'est
excusé moi mais enfin je veux dire 88
morts sur trois millions et demi de
personnes
est ce que c'est un chiffre inquiétant
j'en sais rien je ne peux pas analysé ce
chiffre je ne comprends pas ces chiffres
quand macro un ange le confinement le 16
mars le département à côté du mien
il ya un avion de chasse qui passe le
départ web en donnant le département des
côtes d'armor a repéré un cas un cas
d'accord le 16 mars il ya un cas dans
les côtes d'armor
à partir de là on va faire surveiller
les plages par hélicoptère d'accord pour
empêcher les gens d'aller prendre un peu
l'air les gens qui sont qui sont
confinés dans des lieux parfois dans des
endroits absolument terrible des deux
pièces et ils sortent et ne met
absolument personne en danger n'importe
quelle personne munie d'un cerveau est
capable de comprendre ça j'ai des amis
médecins qui m'ont dit on comprend pas
très bien le coup des hélicoptères parce
qu'il est absolument évident que
quelqu'un qui va sur une plage de mai
personne en danger et c'est donc sous
les 7 questions déchiffrer les ailes et
extrêmement perturbantes
parce que à la fois c'est une
information qui est angoissante
c'est qu'il ya une hystérisation du
problème on nous annonce des nombres de
morts mais en même temps c'est si on met
ces chiffres on regarde d'autres
chiffres
ça devient ça devient presque bizarre
c'est ses 73 mille mans du tabac chaque
année en france
les morts dans les ehpad ses 400 par
jour normalement enfin vous savez on est
on nous a parlé de la grippe saisonnière
tout ça leur faisait toujours des gens
qui disent non non peut pas comparer on
peut toujours comparer l'intérêt de la
comparaison c'est précisément de mettre
des choses qui sont pas acquis sans
qu'ils sont pas les mêmes donc voilà
donc sur cette communication par les
chiffres
je sais pas quoi vous dire je suis
vraiment perplexe ce que j'ai décidé si
d'arrêter d'écouter les informations
parce que c'est terrible c'est
complètement angoissant mais c'est
terrifiant c'est terrifiant enfin vous
pouvez pas tous les quarts d'heure vous
annonce un nombre de morts ok bon après
quand on vous dit par exemple que manu
dibango est mort du corona virus sasser
une nouvelle wii est alors allé aux
prises tous les quarts d'heure sur
france inter ce donc le corps un des
vieux ça tu es manu dibango donc un
artiste sympathique moi je les connais
je veux dire on a inauguré une mjc manu
dibango il est venu c'est un mec sympa
on a discuté toute la soirée
j'adore donc il est mort du coran la
virus match
c'est une sale nouvelle vient juste
après il avait 86 ans non mais la pluie
t'attendais d'accord enfin il est mort
du corps et violet enfin il l'est
peut-être aussi parce qu'il avait 86 ans
enfin je veux dire quelqu'un que
signifie de nous dire que manu dibango
est mort du corps la vie aux caisses que
ça veut nous dire qu'est-ce qui est calé
cette information j'ai reçu manu dibango
ya pas très longtemps dans interdit
d'interdire il se portait très bien je
peux croire effectivement que le cornec
virus est responsable de son décès qui
m'avait semblé comme gelée a pris moi
aussi prématurée mais il a un vécu 6ans
gainage
aujourd'hui on peut vivre assez
longtemps ouais à vous entendre on
dirait qu'il ya un âge au delà duquel on
ne doit plus être là ou en tout cas plus
plus se plaindre si jamais on est obligé
de de partir je mets partir entre
guillemets bien entendu ses 79 ans l'âge
l'ag des hommes en france donc bon ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que quand
on compte comme quand on est dans la
dans la dernière ligne droite
on sait qu'on va mourir lui quelque
chose voilà je sais encore un virus
quand vous attrape les quelque chose
entre 60 à les prendre de mort en
bretagne c'était s'étaient tous 65 79
ans donc voilà bon bref ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que cette
communication par les chiffres
elle et elle et elle est très difficile
à décoder elle est très difficile à
comprendre
et elle est très anxiogène elle est très
effrayante franck lepage un texte
intitulé qu'ovide 19 l'ami des dominants
alors en quoi est ce que cette ce virus
en couille qui est l'ennemi des
dominants parce que nous sommes nous
entrés depuis les années 80 dans une
phase de d'accélération du capitalisme
qui est littéralement entrer en roue
libre à partir du moment où il n'a plus
en face de lui de modèles alternatifs
avec l'écroulement des modèles
communiste le capitalisme n'a plus eu
d'opposants on est rentré dans une phase
extrêmement inquiétante pour les gens et
on le voit dans la façon par exemple
extrêmement fin demain comment je dirais
le gouvernement de maquereaux par
exemple mais encore une fois macron
n'est pas en cause avant lui c'était
resté hollande avant lui c'était sarkozy
avant lui de ses terrasses et un
maquereau n'est que le n'est que
l'exécutant d'une d'une politique qui
s'est mise en place dans les années 80
qu'on appelle le néolibéralisme enfin
bref c'est espèce de capitalisme en roue
libre
7 sept
comment dire ça simplement jeu
capitalisme ne peut plus générer des
profits comme il le faisait jusqu'à
maintenant jusque dans les années 80 à
savoir avec des marchandises qu'on
fabriquait convent le capitalisme je
rappelle est la seule forme connaît où
les cris sont des crises de
surproduction à une crise au moyen-âge
c'est pas ce qui manque quelque chose on
va crever de faim le capitalisme est une
crise génère des crises de surproduction
les voitures de 2018 ne sont toujours
pas vendu pour ça que vous pouvez les
avoir pour tâche est aujourd'hui et ce
qui nous arrive là c'est une nouvelle
crise de surproduction c'est à dire
qu'on va effacer remettre un million de
chômeurs à la rue on va fermer des
petites entreprises on va couler des
artisans on va regrouper des banques
comme ça s'est passé en 2008 comme ça
c'est passé chaque fois qu'il ya une
crise dont on est en train de voir ça
ici
pourquoi est ce qu'on a écrit coville 19
l'ami des dominants mais pour une raison
assez simple c'est que cette crise
permet en grandeur nature de réaliser un
certain nombre de tests qui était rêvée
et réclamé par les dominants par le
patronat depuis les années 80 mais qui
pouvait pas mettre en oeuvre sauf à
mettre tout le monde dans la rue là il
ya un prétexte extraordinaire il ya un
prétexte pour bousiller le droit du
travail
il ya un prétexte pour envoyer tout le
monde à la maison étudier ça c'est le
rêve de l' ocde
bref il ya un prétexte pour transformer
en marche et en marchandises des
services publics c'est à dire des choses
qui jusqu'à maintenant échapper à la
marchandise est-ce que c'est clair ce
que je dis est ce que j'ai besoin de
préciser parce que c'est pas forcément
facile à groupe oui oui
non on comprend on comprend la
marchandisation de ce qui était gratuit
ou en tout cas de ce qui était mutualisé
jusqu'à présent pourraient pas le
premier à le dire non parce qu'il faut
trouver de nouveaux marchés pour générer
de nouveaux profits d'accord c'est à
dire qu'une fois qu'on a une fois que
qu'une clé usb qui est un petit miracle
de technologie est vendu moins cher
qu'un kilo de pommes de terre
ok
la marchandise au musée marx le vieux
barbu avait déjà expliqué ça il ya
longtemps je veux dire la baisse
tendancielle du taux de profit selon
marc c'est exactement ça c'est de dire
les marchandises génère de moins en
moins de profits donc il faut trouver
des nouveaux marchés faut trouver de
nouvelles façons de générer des profits
une de ces nouvelles façons mais c'est
pas la seule une de ces nouvelles façons
c'est de générer des nouveaux marchés et
s'est notamment de mettre la main sur
des choses qui jusqu'à maintenant
étaient des services publics en
particulier par exemple le service
public de la centaine on pourrait parler
si on a le temps aussi du service public
de l'éducation dont on est en train de
faire une expérimentation magnifique de
ce que réclame l'oscd depuis un moment
pour créer un marché éducatif on
supprime les profs on met tout le monde
chez soi on fait de lui leur ning et
c'est donc on est en train
d'expérimenter ça en direct et sur les
politiques de santé
on est on est cette crise tombe à pic
quoi vous ne fait quand même pas partie
de ceux qui pensent qu'on l'a provoqué
cette crise sanitaire
non pas du tout non non non ça c'est je
cherchais ce qu'on appelle les
complotistes bout voilà le problème du
complotistes sait qu'il va chercher des
individus responsables nous fait
l'éducation populaire c'est-à-dire qu'on
cherche l'explication des systèmes par
définition le complotisme ne raisonne
pas en terme de système il va dire c'est
la cia sait pas qui je veux dire il va
il va accuser des gens c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est de regarder ce qui se
passe termes de systèmes ya aussi à
l'oeuvre actuellement un terrible
manichéisme
alors selon où l'on se se place on va
accuser les immigrés les étrangers les
juifs comme autant de la peste noire les
cités qui ne respecteraient pas le con
filmant les riches qui sont partis à la
campagne ou bien qu'ils restent dans
leurs 250 m² à se désaltérer de la sueur
des travailleurs le gouvernement le
medef c'est la faute au patronat vous
même vous dit le patronat se frotte les
mains
vous même vous dit en parlant des
responsables des agences de santé qu'il
le faudra les juger
ensuite est-ce que vous ne
tombez pas dans le manichéisme à votre
tour franck lepage manichéisme ça
voudrait dire qu'il ya des gentils et
des méchants c'est ça c'est ça que
l'autre a tous les défauts et que nous
n'en avons aucun que l'autre est
responsable que nous ne le sommes pas je
sais pas je sais pas répondre à cette
question je pense que je pense que pour
comprendre le capitalisme il faut il
faut retourner à la racine des
phénomènes ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir
une posture radicale
à mon avis ce serait une erreur de
confondre radicalisme et manichéisme
c'est pas parce que vous avez une
posture radicale que vous êtes
nécessairement manichéen je sais pas si
c'est clair ce que je dis pas ce que le
manichéisme
c'est une posture morale ça consisterait
à dire mitterrand était un ok ça
c'est manichéen
non par contre dire mitterrand est celui
qui a liquidé tous les acquis que les
communistes avaient mis en place depuis
47 et qui a enclenché la démolition
absolument continue de toute forme de
protection sociale c'est pas du
manichéisme c'est une analyse radical
qui pourrait se discuter vous la mettez
on n'a pas le temps là mais on pourrait
dire bon c'est pas du terran on pourrait
le dire mais en même temps après il faut
aller sur les faits donc c'est bérégovoy
le premier qui est
qu'ils arrêtent les augmentations de
cotisations qui finance la sécu et puis
ensuite ils vont tous prendre la suite
derrière ces bérégovoy qui prépare le
plan de démolition des retraites que va
mettre en oeuvre commence à balladur
était à l'état donc si vous voulez il ya
une continuité c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça que manichéenne
ça me parle peu même si vous avez raison
qu'il faut se faire attention enfin je
veux dire elle jamais moraliser le
problème je trouve qu'il ya une
continuité absolument commentaire
étonnante enfin d'un dans cette cette
vague de démolition qui fait qu'on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec un hôpital
dans l'état où il est les agences
régionales de santé les ars qu'en tant
qu'homme de façon polémique
on a dit que ça serait pas mal un jour
qui se retrouve devant des tribunaux
étant donné le mal qu'ils ont fait aux
champs ars sont mis en place par sarkozy
le projet est extrêmement simple fin
juillet ici il s'agit de transformer une
politique de soins une politique de
profits sur l'offre de soins
ça peut rendre ça peut rendre volontiers
haineux ça peut rendre colérique
quand je parle de ben ali qu'il ya aussi
le le fait que l'on peut juger de la
complexité avec des avec des alors
peut-être avec radicalisme comme vous
dites ou avec des réflexes simples vous
parlez de nicolas sarkozy ils avaient
pour ministre de la santé roselyne
bachelot
roselyne bachelot à l'époque c'était là
l'épidémie de h1n1
elle avait elle avait collecté des
masques ont été pays qui en avait le
plus à l'époque on en avait un car elle
avait mis en place un comité stratégique
pour lutter contre les prochaines
pandémies
dieu sait si on s'est moqué d'elle à
l'époque les médias sont moqués d'elle
peut être vous même vous êtes vous
moquer d'elle je ne sais pas
le conseil d'état s'est moqué d'elle et
on a finit évidemment par mettre en
pièces tout ce qu'elle avait prévu
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus de base
qu'il n'y a pas de comité stratégique
alors là aussi comment faire cette
complexité parfois elle nous rattrape
avec le temps et estrada se rend compte
que nos deux opinions la guerre si
facile sont en contradiction avec ce que
l'on pense aujourd'hui oui je sais pas
parce que roselyne bachelot encore une
fois est une personne enfin roselyne
bachelot elle
comment dire elle est elle elle peut
faire des trucs chouettes à l'intérieur
d'un système en train d'être démoli il
n'y a pas de cesser c'est pas impossible
du tout j'écoutais quand il s'appelle
sur france inter bruno retailleau uno
retailleau donc la laisse là la
chroniqueuse qui était geneviève fraisse
aux lui de lui dit mais vous étiez avec
fillot donc fillon oui monsieur qui a
obligé d'être confiné avec tous ses
attachées parlementaires là en ce moment
donc j'ai tjrs et vous étiez pour pour
eux pour supprimer 500 fonctionnaires
il y avait il ya une surenchère mois 200
mois 500 et c'est donc elle lui pose la
question à lui disent qu'est ce que ce
qui est en train d'arriver là va vous
faire changer de et imperturbable il dit
mais pas du tout il ya aucune raison de
ralentir les réformes
on a absolument besoin de réformer
l'hôpital
c'est à dire que ces gens-là
continueront imperturbablement c'est ce
travail de démolition
le au contraire c'est pour ça qu'on que
je dis éventuellement c'est une bonne
surprise pour le patronat parce que la
question à se poser c'est qu'est ce
qu'un pouvoir celui de actuellement de
macron qu'est ce qu'un pouvoir qui a
fait autant de mal depuis deux ans aux
gens avaient autant de férocité autant
de sauvagerie qui a attaqué qui accable
défense et le droit du travail la loi
elle comment il s'était déjà mâcon qui a
qui est en train de nous démolir les
retraites qui est en train de les vendre
à blackrock
blackrock qui est reçue à l'elysée
blackrock qui est en train de de
quelqu'un voilà qui quelqu'un quelqu'un
qui commet je dirais qu'ils étaient
engagés dans une dans une telle haine de
classe
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de lui
comment est-ce qu'il va utiliser ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est ça la
question
la question qui fait système si vous
voulez mais vous pourriez vous dire ce
gouvernement aujourd'hui il a mis
l'économie sur pause il a privilégié la
vie humaine
le sauvetage des 1000 même plutôt que le
que le profit à tel point que même
d'autres lui reprochent aujourd'hui en
appliquant aussi drastiquement le
principe de précaution après tout le
confinement c'est le principe de
précaution appliqué drastiquement ces
deux mois qu'on puisse dire va causer
des ravages terribles en terme de
chômage de maladie qui se développe au
moment où on est tous concentrés sur le
grenat virus balle et meurt d'infarctus
d'avc
certains traitements ne sont plus suivis
alors ce gouvernement là encore face à
face à une crise sanitaire hausse
inédite coupable ou au contraire
est ce qu'il fait pas pour le mieux je
ne suis pas en train de défendre mais je
me dis est ce que c'est si simple que
cela
non c'est sûrement pas sans fin mais
comment est ce que vous comprenez par
exemple une politique de confinement
assortie d'une répression que je trouve
moins personnellement quasiment obscène
infliger des amendes de qui vont jusqu'à
3500 euros à des gens qui qui qui gagne
qui sont peut-être au rsa et qui empoche
plus qu'ils sont en train de devenir
dingue dans le confinement et qui vont
essayer de prendre l'air d'accord une
telle violence une telle férocité
jusqu'à des peines de prison ferme et
c'est alors que dans le même temps on
oblige d'aller au travail que les photos
du métro parisien gare du nord à 6
heures du matin montrent des quais
bondés montre des gens à touche-touche
d'accord qu'est ce qu'il raconte ce
gouvernement qu'est ce qui nous dit il
oblige les gens à aller travailler à
paris à 14 millions d'habitants dans un
métro bondé mais il fait surveiller les
plages du finistère par des hélicoptères
dans des excuses mais il a marqué
liberté du conte sur mon front enfin je
veux dire
cc c'est quoi le truc tu dire à quel
moment jusqu'à combien de temps va se
de notre gueule avec ce truc là
je veux dire ce soit il ya un problème
de confinement et on confine soit on
peut envoyer tout le monde bosse et dans
le métro et faut arrêter d'emmerder le
monde parce qu'ils vont prendre l'air
sur une plage donc ce que ce que ce qui
me met la puce à l'oreille c'est là je
le disais tout à l'heure c'est l'âme
la violence de cette répression la
férocité de cette répression sur des
histoires de promenade
ça ça ne va pas vous dîtes effectivement
dans votre texte covit 19 l'ami des
dominants vous dites que
vous ne comprenez pas qu'on ait fermé
les plages mais aussi les parcs les
jardins et éculés une pelisse soit
soient mises en place pour faire
respecter ces interdictions
néanmoins c'est bien que là encore on
est partagé entre le confinement qu'on a
décrété et que le fait qu'il faut bien
ravitailler les gens qui sont confinés
il faut bien qu'ils continuent d'en
gérer donc il faut qu'il y en ait qui
continuent de travailler
et puis qu'on espère aussi que
l'économie ne va pas s'arrêter
totalement parce que sinon on ne pourra
pas indemniser ceux qui aujourd'hui ne
peuvent plus travailler
c'est bien qu'il ya tout ça qui est là
au même moment mais d'accord mais si on
dit aux gens qui vont travailler si ce
gouvernement dit il faut aller bosser
parce que l'économie en a besoin mais
faites attention respectez les mesures
et c'est pourquoi est ce qu'on ne le dit
pas aux gens qu'ils peuvent sortir pour
aller prendre l'air je veux dire les
gens sont parfaitement s'ils sont
capables de respecter des gestes
barrières pour aller travailler doivent
être capables de le faire dans une dans
une forêt à fortiori sur une plage faut
quand même faire très fort pour aller
tout c'est sûr sur le sur l'eau sur
l'oeil de quelqu'un sur une plage je
veux dire le coût de l'hélicoptère et je
trouve extrêmement symptomatique fâche
venir c'est celle là encore vous avez un
test en grandeur nature qui est un test
de l'obéissance de la police est ce que
la police va les cent soixante mille
personnes mobilisées est-ce qu'ils vont
accepter cette cette politique de
répression
c'est un test est ce qu'on va trouver un
gendarme assez avec suffisamment de
neurones dans la tête pour conduire un
hélicoptère au dessus d'une plage pour
traquer une petite vieille qui va
respirer oui manifestement le trou donc
il ya un vrai test en grandeur nature de
contrôle d'une population avec une
répression plus rentable mais qui
s'adresse sur du plaisir de la détente
d'accord mais pas le travail le travail
faut aller bosser par contre eur par
contre se détendent ça c'est pas bien ça
c'est là vous avez une moralisation du
problème enfin c'est insensé
je veux dire je remets pas en cause le
confinement confinement était une des
stratégies possibles on verra dans
quelques années si c'était la meilleure
il ya d'autres pays qui ont fait
différemment mais par contre la
plateforme du confinement
la violence du confinement
là elle pose problème parce qu'il ya
trente six manières de faire un
confinement on pourrait faire un
confinement régionales par exemple on
pourra dire écoutez en bretagne en côtes
d'armor il ya une personne sur une
population de 600 mille habitants bon on
va pas confiné tout de suite d'accord on
pourrait être confiné régionalement le
grand test c'est un pur est confiné
parages ils nous ont suffisamment
racontait que ça touche que les plus de
65 ans massivement à quelques exceptions
près en dessous que ça touche absolument
pas les enfants on aurait pu dire bon
fait vachement gaffe les vieux restez
chez vous et c'est il ya trente six
manières de faire un continent
là je trouve que ma cran s'est fait plus
je vous interromps clos pages on fait
juste une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour dans est interdit
d'interdire avec franck lepage militant
de l'éducation populaire célèbre pour
ses centaines de deux conférences
gesticulées franck lepage nous parlions
vous évoquez le contrôle des populations
qui sévit aujourd'hui dans un pays comme
la france mais que dire des pays
d'autres pays comme taiwan comme samia
pour comme hong kong comme la corée du
sud qui le plus efficacement que nous
semble-t-il contre cette épidémie
mais pour celà dispose de tests
systématiques dès que l'on sort de chez
soi de masques évidemment mais aussi de
traçage informatique via les téléphones
mobiles
est-ce que nous dans notre façon de
contrôler la population est ce qu'on n'a
pas là encore presque un siècle de
retard on est resté au 20e siècle
nous ne sommes pas encore au 21e siècle
en fait j'ai l'impression qu'on y va
vite j'ai l'impression qu'on va
rattraper ce retard très vite les
quelques informations qu'on commence à
voir circuler sur cette grosse boîte
américaine dont le nom m'échappe qui est
en train de vendre un système à l'ap-hp
pour tracer tous les plans là comment
elle s'appelle c'est la boîte la plus
grosse boîte de data
aux etats unis qui en train de vendre sa
espèces c'est à dire l'ensemble de nos
données de santé il y aurait pas eu
encore la ville c'était pas possible je
veux dire il y avait la cnil il y avait
il y avait suffisamment de suffisamment
de gens qui disent on n'est pas d'accord
pour ça c'est là où la crise sanitaire
arrive comme quelque chose d'un peu
magique ça rend d'un seul coup possible
au nom de la santé qu'on fiche tous les
tous les habitants ça rend possible au
nom de la pandémie qu'on surveille leurs
déplacements tout en nous promettant
évidemment qu'il n'y aura pas de
l'utilisation autre que ça ça si loin
dans votre texte
je citais tout à l'heure que 8,19 l'ami
des dominants qui est paru sur le le
site de de l'ardeur vous vous inquiétez
de la privatisation de l'éducation
nationale vous disiez qu'on est en train
de transformer en e-learning et nous en
dira plus
ça c'est assez simple
ça fait depuis le début des années 90
que l' ocde
l'osce et de rafting tanks tra libéral
européen
l'os et des oeufs informe les marchés
que les perspectives de profits je cite
la phrase telle que je meurs je m'en
rappelle exactement les perspectives de
profits sur le marché éducatif pour les
investisseurs institutionnels
donc les fonds de pension les banques
les assurances pour jouer en bourse
les perspectives de profits pour ces
gens là si on arrive à faire un marché
éducatif avec de l'offre d'éducation
sont de l'ordre de 1 à 7 je mets un
euros j'en gagne c'est quand elles ne
sont que de l'ordre de 1 à 2 sur le
marché de la construction automobile
donc on nous informe qu'il ya un marché
qui représente 7000 milliards d'euros en
europe et 20 mille milliards d'euros
dans le monde
si on arrive à faire péter les systèmes
d'éducation nationale si on arrive à
mettre à la place une concurrence
d'offrir d'éducation qui vont passer
évidemment par de l'informatique et ça
fait un certain nombre d'années
maintenant que des gens comme nico hirtt
par exemple en belgique ont alerté le
monde enseignant en disant attention
l'informatique et pas seulement votre
ami méfiez-vous l'informatique va faire
de vous des comment je dirais les
accompagnements des accompagnants de
logiciels et plus des enseignants et je
trouve en regardant un peu ce qui se
passe avec cette fameuse continuité
pédagogique qui absolument pas
pédagogique
[Musique]
et qui n'est pas une continuité d'une
vraie rupture je trouve que ce qui se
passe actuellement c'est que en grandeur
nature ce qu'on n'aurait jamais pu oser
faire avant tout les enseignants sont
d'un seul coup transformé en
accompagnant de contenus de formation
qu'il ce qui ce qu'ils rivalisent de
devoirs à donner aux élèves parce qu'ils
sont surveillés du coup ci c'est
d'informatique
c'est à dire que ce qu'ils font
maintenant leur supérieur hiérarchique
le voit en direct d'accord que les
enseignants que les enfants sont soumis
à une productivité absolument démente un
enfant je rappel c'est en maternelle 4
minutes de capacité d'adaptation
continue de d'attention continuer pour
nadine que ces 25 minutes
là il se retrouve en mode je produis je
produis je produis je produis autrement
dit on a vraiment un système
d'accélération de là je sais pas comment
appeler ça de la performance de
productivité si les scolaires avec des
profs qui ne sont plus des profs se
terminait fin je veux dire c'est hermine
en très peu de temps ils sont juste là
pour accompagner le logiciel qui lui va
évaluer etc etc
avec derrière de très grandes firmes des
éditeurs de logiciels un derrière vous
allez retrouver sûrement les achète et
lagardère tous ces gens là ils sont
prêts ils attendent ils attendent que ça
donc ça une explosion des inégalités
dans ce système ça c'était tellement
évident enfin je veux dire les parents
qui sont pas capables de comprendre les
problèmes de trigonométrie de leurs
gamins dans les classes populaires etc
enfin je veux dire c'est c'est du
bonheur c'est du bonheur gers que
l'école ne pouvait pas faire même si la
réforme bancaire est en train d'aller
vers ça même si et c'est là le qu'ovide
19 d'un seul col offre sur un plateau
d'où cette phrase tout à fait étonnant
d'ailleurs de blanquet nous étions prêts
depuis plusieurs semaines il dit ça en
février
qu'ils prennent à quoi ça fait un moment
que ça ferrand qui réfléchit ça ça fait
un moment que l' ocde que prévoit que la
privatisation de l'éducation nationale
le système éducatif va passer par une
informatisation par le fait de mettre
les gosses à la maison et non plus à
l'école et donc on est en train de faire
un test
c'est ça qui est intéressant ce qu'ils
on est en train de faire un test en
grandeur nature
on n'est pas en train de tester dans une
zone dans un machin dans quatre écoles
on est en train de faire un test
national dont on va pouvoir tirer les
conclusions d'ailleurs elle est déjà des
politiques qui disent c'est pas mal ça
marche pas mal en fait il ya d ivoire d
voilà on est en train d'assister à ça on
pourrait imaginer vous avez été
instituteur je crois franck lepage on
pourrait imaginer effectivement que se
servir d'internet pour imaginer par
exemple que hong hong et les cours des
meilleurs profs au monde sur son nom sur
son internet et puis qu'ensuite on
allait faire ses devoirs à l'école
là il y aurait plus les problèmes
d'inégalité dont vous parlez et on
passerait moins de temps à l'école après
tout on nie pas cela peut peut-être un
peu trop ton nom on pourrait imaginer
oui effectivement je crois pas que c'est
ça qui va se passer
bon mais ça ce serait pas idiot
reconnaissez le sauf que vous raisonnez
comme vous faites ça en termes de
performances et est donc est ce que
l'école est le lieu qui doit pousser la
performance
oui non la performance dans
l'apprentissage bien sûr bien sûr je
veux dire les profs qui sont
complètement en train de ils sont en
train de devenir dingue a essayé de
faire appliquer un programme qui est
beaucoup trop important pour qu'on
puisse le faire un entier d'accord ils
sont tous en train de devenir fou avec
ça je dire là le logiciel permet d'aller
beaucoup plus loin
est-ce que l'école est là pour éduquer
la société ce qu'est l'école est là pour
pour former des enfants de plus en plus
performants dans une espèce de
compétition complètement débridé après
c'est la question de l'optimist du
pessimiste je sais pas si vous
connaissez cette black bloc soviétique à
monsieur beaucoup marqué c'est un
optimiste qui rencontre un pessimiste et
le pessimiste dire la catastrophe la
situation ça va pas du tout ça va pas du
tout ça ne pourrait pas être pire et
l'optimiste ray pour messi messi
d'accord c'était l'été veille très bonne
blague optimiste c'est à dire que je
sais que ça peut être pire
oak lepage vous parlez aussi de deux des
progrès de la vidéo médecine à distance
vous l'avais dit il ya deux secteurs
entiers ou le lait part du service
public sont encore importantes c'est la
santé et l'éducation dans ces deux
domaines on peut espérer privatiser
marchandises et faire du profit mais en
quoi la médecine les aujourd'hui les des
consultations qui se font à distance
parce qu on est confiné en quoi
pourrait-elle représenter l'avenir de la
médecine je suis pas suffisamment
spécialistes sur cette question pour
pour aller très loin
ce que je peux dire c'est que l'outil
n'est qu'un outil l'informatique c'est
qu'un outil mais un outil n'est pas
qu'un outil
on est en train d'assister à la
troisième révolution de l'humanité là je
vais voilà je gagnais un camembert à
trivial pursuit puisque après la
révolution agricole avec l'invention de
la roue et la révolution industrielle
dont on va crever dans très peu de temps
avec le pétrole et la crise écologique
mais en est engagé dans une nouvelle
révolution qu'il a réussi en forme multi
on est incapable de prévoir ce qui va se
passer en termes de modification des
métiers dc dc est d'ici 10 ans d'ici à
dix ans on est incapable de prévoir ce
que l'informatique va nous amener tel un
aimant ça va vite
vous imaginez que ils en sont déjà à
leur connaissance face chine sur une
population et a donc donc ça va
extrêmement on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer
donc si vous me dites ça peut être
formidable ça peut être très chouette ça
peut être ça va permettre de faire des
tas de choses formidables en médecine on
a des opérations qui sont maintenant
en face on informatique c'est vrai c'est
sûr c'est certain et puis vous avez le
versant extrêmement inquiétant des
choses
donc là encore tout tout tout tout va
être une question est question politique
je sais pas quoi vous dire
la médecine la médecine informatisé je
regarde mes notes parce que j'ai je
détruis faut pas que j'oublie de dire ça
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose que vous
venez de lire lac vouliez pas oublier de
dire quand il a eu la gentillesse de
dire qu'on s'occupait de conférences
gesticulées en fait quand je pense qu'on
est en train de faire dans un réseau
d'éducation populaire qui comporte
plusieurs associations plusieurs score
qu'en france qu'on peut repérer assez
facilement
c'est qu'on est en train de seuil et de
donner la parole à des gens pour qu'ils
témoignent de la sonde met en place la
domination dans leur secteur
un peu à l'image d'un puzzle ce qui ce
qui nous intéresse dans politiquement
parlant dans la crise actuellement je
suis pas épidémiologistes vraiment je
vais pas dire des choses sur cette
maladie je veux dire je vais pas prendre
le risque de dire des bêtises donc bon
en revanche à force d'observer la façon
dont on a démoli la formation
professionnelle avec la loi sur la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel c'est la noix qu un très
joli nom la façon dont on a démoli le
l'accompagnement des chômeurs qui est l
anpe avec pôle emploi et cetera
on voit on voit se mettre en place un
ensemble de choses qui si on les prend
qui isolément ne font pas sens que si
vous la question de la santé
vous pouvez dire oui bon bah il faut
moderniser l'hôpital mais c'est pas ça
la question je dis yes et ses cités de
trois bouquins je suis tombé sur le
bouquin de johann chapoutot qui
s'appelle libre d'obéir il vient de
sortir ce bouquin le
alors accrochez vous parce que le sous
titre va faire va piquer un peu le
management du nazisme a aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il raconte le bouton y
chapoutot c'est un type très serré vous
pouvez si vous aussi vous pouvez voir
ses comptes
c'est un spécialiste du nazisme
d'accord le nazisme c'est quoi c'est le
capitalisme dans ses versions absolue je
voulais c'est le capitalisme en roue
libre sans aucune sans aucune sans
aucune opposition vous arrivez au
fascisme nazi c'est à dire un système où
fait travailler les gens et ensuite on
les en les enlevant l'effet crevé au
travail tu sais je rappelle que je suis
vite c'est un camp de travail d'abord
qu'est ce qui dit chapeau ce que les
nazis avaient une horreur de l'état de
l'état protecteur de l'état qui donne
des allocations à des chômeurs et que ce
que ce que vont faire les nazis c'est
qu'ils vont démolir un par un les
services publics et les remplacer par
des agences
là vous vous dites tiens tiens tiens
c'est marrant il ya des agences
régionales de santé
on a démoli la formation professionnelle
en france on l'a remplacé par une agence
qui s'appelle france compétences pour
l'emploi c'est à dire que vous voyez des
tendances se mettre à l'oeuvre qui sont
celles dont je parlais tout à l'heure je
peux en train de dire que mc ren est un
nazi je suis en train de dire que la
pente naturelle d'un capitalisme qui
n'est plus réguler n'est plus débris et
quand on parle actuellement de 2,2 de
dérive je sais pas si vous avez vu ça il
ya des émissions sur france inter
j'aime beaucoup ça y at-il de dérive
autoritaire du gouvernement macro ça me
fait beaucoup rigolé il n'y a plus
qu'une dérive autoritaire vous avez
correctionnel
emmanuel todd il vient d'écrire un
bouquin qui s'appelle les luttes de
classes en france 21e siècle un toad
parle de dérive fascistoïde de la macro
ni c'est pareil c'est pas macron aux
problèmes macro n'est que le
représentant d'une dune d'un capitalisme
livré à lui même au delà de la
comparaison
deux chapiteaux semble-t-il entre le
nazisme et capitalisme vous même plus
prosaïquement vous dites que le patronat
aujourd'hui se frotte les mains
mais non alors que alors même que les
contrats de les commandes les carnets de
commandes sont vides que les échanges
commerciaux
sautons point mort que les pme sont pour
la plupart dans les plus grandes
difficultés qu'un certain nombre de
multinationales sont proches de la
faillite et que de très grand pro
capitalistes comme comme donald trump
par exemple se semblait encore ya peu
totalement allergique au confinement
parce que justement c'était mettre le
capitalisme à rude épreuve alors comment
pouvez vous penser que le
le patronat les capitalistes aujourd'hui
on quoi que ce soit à gagner du
confinement
encore une fois on analyse enfin en bout
en bout marxisme amateurs parce que mais
parce que ça permet de liquider une
partie de l'appareil productif et que le
patronat a toujours fait ça simplement
dans quand on parle du prêtre faut pas
mettre dans le même sac le medef et les
petites pme
le medef est pas le copain des pme c'est
insupportable cette façon de kant macron
dit on va aider l'entreprise qui dit pas
on va aider les salariés à il dit on va
pas augmenter les salaires
on va aider les propriétaires des
entreprises les propriétaires des
grandes entreprises
est ce qu'ils se frottent les mains est
ce que les traders se frotte les mains
par exemple
d'accord c'est d'un trader c'est pas de
financer l'économie réelle c'est de
jouer sur des os et des et des baisses
là c'est ce et ses festivals pour bien
vous avez des pour ceux qui ont joué à
la baisse mépris pour ceux qui ont joué
à la hausse évidemment évident
je veux dire il y en a qui vont jouer à
la baisse enfin je verse et c'est
formidable c'est génial vd baisse de 14%
des remontées de 5% fin c'est le sait le
celle là c'est la fête chez les traders
pour les bourses en ce moment je veux
dire rappelez vous comment ce rose se
fait c'est fait d'aider des sommes
d'argent considérables en pariant sur la
chute de la livre en pariant sur la
dette grecque et c'est donc clair quand
vous dites le patronat le patronat le
patronat ça dépend desquels patronat on
parle encore une fois c'est ce que je
voulais vous entendre dire ce qu'ils
vont en baver c'est les petits patrons
ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr mais bon il ya
un moment il va falloir qu'ils
choisissent leur camp qu'ils arrêtent de
croire que le medef et leurs potes
comment ça c'est un problème milite
depuis longtemps que les travailleurs
doivent devenir les propriétaires de
leur outil de travail les travailleurs
pas l'état non non surtout pas l'état
non bien sûr
bon ça là je cite lui bernard friot un
bernard friot que vous avez fait
intervenir je crois déjà
c'est notre président est venu dans
cette émission est effectivement là
bernard friot selon nous le seul la
seule perspective crédible à gauche
aujourd'hui est une une de ces
hypothèses est effectivement qu'il est
temps que les travailleurs se deviennent
propriétaires de leur outil de travail
ça passe par des flandres coopérative ça
passe par des choses comme ça c'est la
seule façon de s'en sortir ça sera ça
c'est sûr c'est certain voilà c'est très
simple que les actions les actionnaires
doivent être révélées va c'est sans
indemnisation et les prêteurs non
remboursés oui tout à fait c'est que ça
mais à ce moment là
pour google c'est pareil que pour la
petite pme
j'imagine que les bus les travailleurs
deviennent propriétaires de google et
tous deviennent du jour au lendemain
millionnaires ou milliardaires surtout
s'ils n'ont plus besoin de rembourser
leurs actionnaires
vous allez fabriquer alors des pauvres
d'à côté mais des très très riches de
l'autre
ne croyez vous pas non mais ça ça se
fera pas du jour au lendemain
enfin je vais on n'est pas en train de
parler du grand soir
ce que ce que dit bernard friot et très
j'ai dit ça ça a pris cinq siècles la
bourgeoisie pour prendre le pouvoir ça
prendra encore pas mal de temps pour que
les travailleurs prennent le pouvoir
la question est de savoir vers où on va
la question est de savoir quand on l'a
on va dans le mur enfin je viens
vraiment c'est facile à voir
la crise du coronavirus elle met en
lumière plein de choses déjà sur les
restrictions de la recherche sur des
choses je préfère des exemples personne
j'ai un beau frère qui était chercheur
il travaillait sur des trucs très
pointue avec des irm là sur le
l'infarctus électrique du cerveau de la
souris là c'est un type passionné de
recherche il travaillait à quand il a
arrêté
il a donné sa démission il a donné sa
démission à partir du moment où
plusieurs années consécutives il s'est
rendu compte que son métier c'était plus
de faire de la recherche c'était de
faire des montages de dossiers de
financement
ben voila voila c c c c c on est en
train de transformer la recherche en une
entreprise comme on transforme l'hôpital
une entreprise les gens ne peuvent plus
soignée qui sont plus en train de faire
du soin ils sont en train de faire du
fric les infirmières comment ça se met
en place un truc comme ça ça se met en
place avec des outils comme la démarche
qualité par exemple la démarche qualité
est une saleté qui est en train de
flinguer tous les services publics et de
transformer tout le monde en une espèce
de robots qui n'a plus de métier qui
suit des protocoles et bien la démarche
qualité est en train de flinguer secteur
après secteur la formation continue etc
etc etc
demander aux infirmières ce qu'elle en
pense est ce qu'elle pense qu'elles ont
encore un métier quand elle doit faire
de la traçabilité je sais pas combien
d'heures par jour etc
elles n'ont plus de métier c'est le
philosophe je crois c'est le
psychanalyste christophe dejours je
crois que c'est lui qui disait
travailler ses trouvailles et quand on a
plus de cantons peu plus inventer son
métier on a plus de métier et l'hôpital
on prend l'exemple de l'hôpital mais on
pourrait parler des profs on pourrait
paraître plein d'autres secteurs mais
l'hôpital et dans un dans un désarroi
enfin absolument mais inimaginable une
conférence gesticulée de d'elisabeth
féerique et aides soignants dans un
ehpad puisqu'on est là on a parlé des
ehpad sont nepad a été racheté par un
fonds de pension américain du du coup
ils sont pas ils ont une diminution du
personnel par trois c'est à dire qu'au
lieu d'avoir trois personnes pour
surveiller la nuit 80 80 personnes en
grande dépendance y en a plus qu'une
ils sont passés de une douche par jour à
une douche par semaine
je voudrais savoir le ministre de la
santé là combien de douchy prend par
semaine ça l'intéresserait ils n'ont
plus de couches peuvent pas changer les
vieux qui se pisser qui ce qui sonne qui
se font dessus non plus assez de couches
y sont obligés d'aller piquer des
couches dans d autres services en un
cancéreux et c'est pour pouvoir etc et
donc ça c'est ça c'est très concret ça
c'est le résultat d'une transformation
des ehpad en en est en comment je dirais
en matières à profits
est-ce que vous avez est ce que vous
avez reçue est ce que ça vous est arrivé
il ya quelques temps d'aller sur météo
france
non ça m'est jamais venu à l'esprit à
l'esprit malade et il ya des pubs sur
météo france
et il ya quelques mois il y avait une
pub qui reste et qui est restée en ligne
un certain nombre de chaque fois qu'on
est sur météo france
moi je fais du parapente donc je vais
tous les jours sur météo france pour
savoir si je peux voler
il y avait une pub qui disait
investissez dans les ehpad rendement
garanti à 11%
je ne comprenais pas assez de pub
comment comment est ce qu'on a investi
dans un ehpad
c'est très simple vous achetez une
chance vous devenez propriétaire de la
chambre et vous la louer à des vieux qui
viennent mourir là quand vous garantit
durance % d'accord voilà
voilà la situation des ehpad aujourd'hui
en france à part ça n'empêche pas les
médias dominants et puis le gouvernement
de pleurer sur la situation de ces
pauvres ehpad qui sont attaquées par le
virus
je dirais on se fout du monde à venir
c'est quand même extraordinaire franck
lepage
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup des
inégalités à croire que le confinement
les églises encore davantage c'est vrai
que certains sont coincés dans des
surfaces réduites et le fait de ne pas
pouvoir sortir les rend plus réduites
encore vous même vous militez pour que
les salaires pour le salaire à vie de
bernard friot et que les salaires ne ne
qu'on puisse pas aller plus loin que de
1 à 3 c'est toujours le cas c'est une
proposition de bernard friot
effectivement à 3 à 4 peu importe mais
c'est vraiment ça la perspective
révolutionnaire qui sait d'attaché on va
pas faire on va pas reprendre son
hypothèse parce qu'elle vaut mieux aller
voir directement la source mais l'idée
qu'il a assez bien expliquée dans cette
émission il suffit de se reporter a
interdit d'interdire avec bernard friot
en 1985 qui s'appelle viviane forrester
je crois a écrit un livre qui s'appelait
l'horreur économique dans l'horreur
économique elle dit on est en train de
modifier le système de production de
façon à ce que y'a rien de plus en plus
de gens privés d'emploi privées de et
l'informatique va décupler sa toutes les
professions du transport vont sauter
puisque maintenant les baigneurs se
conduisent toute seules etc et viviane
forrester poser une question très
intéressante elle dit ok tant qu'on est
dans un état démocratique
ces gens qui sont en trop qui n'ont pas
d'emploi qu'on peut pas employer
d'accord puisque on emploie les gens que
quand on peut faire du profit avec dans
ce système
bon on va leur donner des indemnités
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si le régime
bascule et qui cesse d'être une
démocratie qu'est ce que ces gens
deviennent et qu'est ce qu'on va en
faire
et bien ce que dit effectivement todd
c'est que quand on est actuellement dans
une dérive fascistoïde de ce système
c'est à dire que à tout moment ce
système peut dériver
quand on a un gars comme macro et qu'on
lui confie un truc comme la vème
république qui est vraiment vraiment une
saloperie veut dire la vème république
est un régime présidentiel qui a été mis
en place dans des circonstances très
particulières pour un général dans une
situation de guerre d'algérie ok c'est
une situation qui annule complètement le
parlement le parlement ne sert
strictement à rien vous regardez les 308
marionnettes qui ont été engagés pour
servir de paillasson à maquereau en un
été 2010 est le pardon c'est un donc
c'est un régime présidentiel qui permet
de donner les pleins pouvoirs moi je dis
que macro et est à quelques encablures
de faire agir l'article 16 jeudi quand
on voit comment il a traité les gilet
jaune qui était un mouvement
extraordinaire un mouvement populaire
magnifique
je suis très fier d'habiter un pays qui
a connu les gilet jaune quand on voit la
répression du mouvement social qui là
qu'il a engagée contre toute forme de
manifestation gazés tout le monde
d'entrée cetera
on se dit que ce ce régime peut basculer
puis c'est pas le seul c'est en train de
bouger comme ça partout dans le monde
vous le savez est donc la question c'est
que si ces gens sont en trop les gens
qui ne sont rien comme dirait macro il a
eu cette très jolie formule qu'est ce
qu'ils vont devenir
c'est pour ça que la réponse de free est
intéressante friot dit tout français à
sa majorité devrait avoir un droit à un
salaire attachés à ces personnes de même
qu'il a le droit de vote de même qu'il a
des droits de et c'est ça devrait être
un droit et ensuite on fait évoluer ça
c'est une hypothèse qui se mettra pas du
jour au lendemain en route mais c'est la
seule hypothèse sur laquelle on peut
cheminer pour sortir de ce système qui
nous emmène dans le mur
pour ça il faut créer un rapport de
merci franck lepage de nous avoir
accordé toute une heure portez vous bien
et j'espère à bientôt en chair et en os
merci de nous avoir subi et rendez vous
au prochain numéro
[Musique]